[Music]
where do you think we should come
wherever just enjoy every second of
getting the heck out of Ludlow
[Applause]
what the hell is that
[Music]
first place I learned about death was a
pet cemetery
[Music]
secret place
generation to Generation Dead things
buried in that land
but come back
there's something else
[Applause]
can you hear them
voices
I think something's wrong with Timmy he
needs time to adjust
the people built the pet cemetery to
protect them from evil
[Music]
well what have you done
we have to find Tim
now stop this I held him the day he came
into this world and I'm gonna hold him
the day he goes out
believe me when I say
sometimes dead is better
[Music]
foreign